i have such a full life i feel like now
i know the reason why i was born beyonce
shares a rare glimpse inside her life as
a mom just one day before queen bee
drops her highly anticipated album
renaissance
[Music]
the mom of three posted a makeup free
pick on her website of the carter kids
10 year old blue ivy and five-year-old
twins roomie and sir taking a cat nap
with bee the singer is famously private
about her family life so it's nice to
see mama be in her natural element
of course the beehive is on pins and
needles waiting for the release of
renaissance on july 29th marking b's
sick studio album
[Music]
in her latest newsletter yonsei shared a
special message teasing how her new
sound came to life in the middle of the
pandemic and we back outside we set you
outside but you ain't that outside
quote creating this album allowed me a
place to dream and to find escape during
a scary time for the world
as for this new renaissance era b says
this album allowed her a place to scream
release and feel freedom
and the praise continues she's a
super um detail oriented obviously as
you can see from her work and she's a
incredibly hard worker
queen bee dedicated a sweet message to
her husband jay-z for holding her down
in the studio and their three kids for
supporting her while making the record
quote i want to give a special thank you
to roomie sir and blue for allowing me
the space creativity and inspiration it
feels good to know that the hard work
paid off of course this isn't the first
time her family has inspired her music
blue ivy's had a hand in a couple of
these projects she even won a grammy for
this heartfelt track
[Music]
and b's all about putting family first
so you know the inner circle gets
exclusive first listing of these new
tunes
you forget that
mama tina told etb's latest album has
been a true labor of love she put two
years of love into this
many many nights all night working and
so i can't wait for the for the world to
hear it
meanwhile her bff and destiny's child
bandmate kelly rowland is clearly
impressed but staying tight-lipped
i know you've heard beyonce's album how
is it
hi i don't know what you're talking
about how's that out oh come on
come on now you won't break myself
thankfully once the clock strikes
midnight fans will be able to listen for
themselves
[Music]